this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck and
minimalists hello everybody welcome to
the minimalist podcast we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
Ryan Nicodemus is not here today because
today we're gonna talk about hormones so
I wanted a woman to be here and it just
so happens that I know a woman just one
my wife is here Rebecca Sharon is here
also
Adam Lam is here because actually one of
the person who really knows about
hormones so Adam lamb from renew life rx
com is the website we were talking to
you today Adam about what we've got a
bunch of audience questions but I
thought this was perfect because Bex and
I have really been reassessing our sort
of life as we approach age 40 we are we
are starting to question and figure out
what is optimal for us as we get a
little bit older and so I want to talk
about hormones both female and male
hormones and how they change as we get
into our 30s and 40s and 50s and beyond
and I want to talk about what we can do
to optimize our hormones to get the best
out of life how our hormones affect our
sleep are our stress our mood our energy
our sex drive and then also the opposite
of that how does our diet and sleep and
and sunlight and exercise affect our
hormones we're also going to talk about
hormone testing today because that's a I
think a critical component of all of
this so I've noticed recently Beck's and
I were just talking about this we
haven't had many women on the podcast
recently that isn't for try I last
couple weeks actually less what was a
Shawn I think we've had five weeks in a
row where we've had to reschedule
different women who for being on the
podcast so they've they've rescheduled I
guess because of the I hear there's a
pandemic going on and it's a bit more
difficult to get here right now right
and so Bex is here I want to talk to you
about your hormones Adam I want to talk
to you about her hormones as well right
she's very hormonal we all know Adam
when we talked about we talked about
hormones it's this catch-all term right
is kind of like saying sports right away
what do we mean because vitamin D is a
hormone but testosterone is also a
hormone what are we talking about when
we talk about hormones
yeah and it's a great question I think
that probably one of the biggest dis
services to hormones as we talked about
it as a blanket statement you know even
when you look at you talk you just
mentioned sports and you see something
you're like oh let me look at the
genetics and that guy uh-huh that's
hormones there's a it's not like
necessarily genetic to genetically have
good hormones that are helping them be
optimal and a Performa performance
standpoint for example I think that
there's just different hormones through
our life that matter more especially for
women as you know estrogen and some of
it the progesterone and the things that
help with baby-making are important but
when you're done making babies it's not
as important it's still important
because they're all important we want to
have balance and so we really have to go
through you know what we do at our
company is go through individually and
see like what is important to you
because what leads people to us it's not
like they look in the mirror they go
yeah my testosterone must be off right
they just they feel things they read
things they research things and then we
do a blood test and we confirm what they
believe and what they feel and we find
out what what needs to be optimizing
right and because I think most of the
time like when I got my and we're
actually we have some test results
printed out here before and after tests
for me index which we'll try to get to
if not here at least on the the maximal
episode but you know I didn't know much
about DHEA I mean I knew about
testosterone and its role and I but all
of these other sort of ancillary
hormones and they're all sort of working
together right they're not standing in
separate corners of the room here right
yeah there is a harmony between the
hormones and you know a lot of times too
there's misconception behind hormones so
when you we talk about testosterone we
primarily think men right right we don't
think it's gonna it's a big factor in
women you know I could just think of a
female friend of mine she's 31 she was
just in her office and I'll use her as
an example
she's you'd look at her she's fit she's
good-looking works out all the time
you would say there's nothing wrong with
you but she knows that based on how
she's eating how hard she has to work
out and those things she knows or
something
right but she's 31 she should be healthy
she looks great we check her blood work
she is the testosterone of a 70 year old
woman right and so the the things that
she knows about herself we don't know
outside and even you know your average
OBGYN or doctor would say hey look
you're looking good you're fine you
should you must be fine right and so but
it can also then change his and had her
cycle hasn't been normal in six months
and so like all these other things you
know got married and they compile right
and often we overlook what could be
going on that you can't solve which is
potentially a hormone issue and then
there are some things to do around it
and actually you noticed this in your
own life like to me yeah you you you
were the sort of paragon of health to me
but you also notice there are a few
things off and if if you I think if you
go to your average doctor of it and even
if they look at some test results they
might say it's fine and use that word
fine normal right normal but normal
isn't optimal or even good necessary
when you look at the range on a test
you're like normal and I always used it
joke kind of hey if nor if I had the
decision to pay you thirty thousand a
year or a hundred and twenty thousand a
year which one do you want
I want one hundred and twenty right and
so if you want it your hormones to be
optimal do you want the low or do you
want the it's normal right and so that's
something that we kind of chase after is
not so much the number as much as how
the number reflects how you feel and how
healthy you are right because that's the
other factor because you can feel great
and things are going on inside that are
good too so we always so look at those
things especially in the US population
and I'm not sure where the reference
ranges come from but like normal in the
u.s. is not healthy right
right right and I would argue far from
optimal for most people or at least for
people that are striving to feel better
to perform better to look better perhaps
and that's the number one thing is most
the people we work with are paying
attention to what they eat they're
paying attention to how they move you
know like exercise whatever they
whatever their thing is and they're
noticing that things aren't adding up
anymore right and it's part of it
sometimes we talk about just getting
older well so what like what does that
mean I have to like
not be as happy and I shouldn't get the
results from the effort like and then
people throw in the towel or we look at
it and say yeah we can just optimize
this and this and all sudden you're back
to feeling how you want to feel which
usually promotes better health anyway
right right well I was gonna go in that
exact same direction like as you age and
if you're still putting forward the
effort but not seeing the results and
you're feeling kind of worse and worse
then you're like well screw it like why
am I doing this and you just kind of
keep letting it slide and it perpetuates
that sort of you know fall into
middle-age later a degeneration of our
bodies and because you were exercising
that you stops or now you're not as
strong you're more likely to get injured
as you're older and things like that you
know having strength as you age is
what's gonna help you avoid major
pitfalls like those you're like I think
we're young but you know like that 70s
and 80s I hope we all get there and keep
cranking through and I want to be like
annoyingly energetic right my great Mark
Sisson level of like fitness yeah and I
mean clearly he he optimizes things not
now Beck's let me let me talk to you
about what were you experienced in the
made you start to say well maybe there's
some tweaks that need to happen even
before getting a blood test yeah so over
the course of the last winter I we
should say you're 21 thank you I was
over about 38 to be clear yeah I'm 38
now as 37 this winter but yeah so I
generally struggle a bit with like
seasonal affective disorder thankfully
since I've been able to come back and
forth to LA from Montana that's been
better
but it was bad this winter and it was
like it was not just seasonal affective
disorder it was like I feel depressed
you know a malaise that yeah and there
wasn't like any dietary reason there
wasn't really any tangible lifestyle
reason I was still you know getting in
good workouts or putting in effort I
wasn't seeing the results that I wanted
so that was another more depressed
exactly why yeah I think if you're
hitting ice cream every night right just
stop working out you knew why yeah
No and so just felt like this cycle of
like depression lack of energy lethargy
malaise and like I was getting crushed
by my workouts that was one thing that
was just like a huge red flag was I was
not recovering I was having trouble
getting through them despite not really
changing anything on the on the diet
front so yeah that was kind of and I
think there were some other things there
there was there was sleep right sleep
issues and we can really look we'll go
more into sleep but there were just some
signs in fact I've got this article that
we'll talk about on the maximal what to
know about hormone imbalances and some
of the the symptoms to say well you've
got hormone imbalances name something
they can go wrong with you and it might
have something to do with with hormone
imbalance in a way right or sure it
changes in heart rate brittle weak bones
difficulty sleeping irritability and
anxiety increased thirst headaches
bloating reduced sex drive these are all
things that I want to talk about today
now Adam you yeah a tree new life rx
your company which is based in Houston
but you deal with people all over the
place yeah we're nationwide so we have
physicians throughout the country I just
physically sit there it's it's a
telemedicine hormone replacement therapy
so the reason we do that is it started
with a lot of our client base was just
were people that needed the service of
helping facilitate that process right to
get to the doctor's get the blood work
unit all organized and so we built it
really at a more of a high touch point
customer care service not like a usual
medical experience right and this is the
question I've been asking recently over
the last couple years is as I'm getting
older is hormone replacement therapy
right but what I like about your
approach to all of this is you tend to
make sure people have the other boxes
checked first it's not putting a
band-aid on a problem if I'm eating
Twinkies every day and out drinking at
night and not sleeping much or and I'm
not exercising you at first you checked
those boxes to make sure I was doing the
the appropriate things before asking
okay if you've optimized the
areas of your life now maybe and you ask
questions like how do you sleep and and
what are your sleep patterns and stuff
once that's figured out that's when you
look at the hormones right that all
matters and we want to go into this with
the right expectation right so like if
you're eating fast food five days a week
and you're drinking six beers every
night in the couch and you're about 50
pounds overweight and you haven't worked
out since you're in college we're
probably not the first place for you
right you may need Tony Robbins not all
right so motivate you keep going and so
but the folks that are like I said
paying attention right like like Rebecca
said I she just noticed something was
off right and we just noticed like
there's no reason why I shouldn't have
the libido I have today or there's no
reason why like my body just I'm doing
the same stuff it's not it's not working
right so they're paying attention we
have a solution for it and then then
going through that conversation right we
talk we talk about how will you manage
stress where does your life look like
because when we can get a little bit of
a grip and some awareness on other
things about like sleep for example
people no one sleeps good right so we
always are trying to figure that out and
then like so like you know Ben will talk
about different sleep routines right so
sometimes I'm watching some something
stressful on the TV and then try to hop
in bed and fall asleep it's not going to
work as well as having a 20 minute
stretch routine and screens that like
you know so we we just try to bring that
awareness to that stuff to say hey
listen this isn't the magic pill or this
isn't the magic process of hormones but
we're definitely going to help these
these areas so that you can actually
manage some these other areas we've got
some questions from our audience today I
thought we'd go ahead and dive into
those our first one is from Hannah in
San Diego she writes in and says how
does stress affect our hormones and I
guess I would have pin that question by
saying what else affects our hormones
and and how do we naturally regulate our
hormones so some of the things you you
just touched on there we but how does
hell distress negatively or positively
affect our hormones well when you think
of so other parts of our hormones like
the fight-or-flight hormones right so
the the if everything is an emergency
everything's 911 everything in your
phone every email like all that stuff
your cortisol levels are cranking your
Adrenaline's cranking like you're just
always stressed and when you're doing
that you're flooding your system
with hormones that are not necessary
right because you're just you're
psychologically managing something a
little bit different so that that is it
just crushes DHEA levels and
testosterone levels and it really can
cause a lot of bad balance in the body
right and so that's why like I said just
a second ago we talked about stress we
talked about what stresses you out how
do you manage little bit and we can look
at you know someone's DHEA levels and
just say hey look we can increase DHEA
it's a supplement you can get
over-the-counter and actually help
regulate your cortisol levels so that
you can sleep better and then you may
find less stress less anxiety right and
and it's just having the right hormones
sometimes in the right place that's
needed but your stress and my stress and
Becca stress can be different so we all
need something different and the best
way to figure that out is to look at the
blood work yeah right is it doesn't lie
and so we always with it model we say
stop guessing and start testing it's
kind of cheesy but it's real right it
works um some of the other things though
is you know we especially testosterone
too often is equated to you know working
out and strength and athleticism and you
know muscles and stuff like that which
scares women often but the reality is is
testosterone can help from confidence
right just like I could say if your
testosterone so I could say hey Josh
good new haircut and you could be like
me and Adam doesn't like my haircut it
but if your testosterone is high you
might say alright yeah I'm looking good
and it's a difference of how sometimes
we see ourselves based on where our
hormone levels are right and
testosterone can be a big indicator with
I mean you're thinking of decision
making better right let's wish Washee on
things and all that stuff confidence and
all those things come from our hormones
right and it's having the the right
amount as well because you can also look
at you know the average prisoner in
America the prison population has some
of the highest testosterone right in our
country as well I have a doctor friend
of mine who brings us up every time we
talk about a testosterone and my retort
to that is yeah you can also look at the
NBA and find some of the highest
testosterone Ilana prism as well as so
like it's it's having the optimal levels
now backs when when we did the tests you
were
you were shocked by how low your your
testosterone levels were as well shocked
and not shocked okay I'm shocked and
relieved yeah that an answer yeah you
know which is usually the goal right
find the solution you talk about that
how low my testosterone was yeah sure
women don't think I mean especially a
woman your age you're not really
thinking about like I need to increase
my testosterone I mean even though you
do effectively what I would call
CrossFit workouts it doesn't have that
moniker but when I see what's going on
at your gym it's it's basically that
yeah yeah I guess I prior to getting Tet
doing the testing I just assumed that
I'd have decent testosterone because you
know I I do weightlifting weight
training like and not just like high
reps low weights it's like throw weights
around and but it also didn't surprise
me you know I was on birth control the
hormonal birth control for over a decade
over a decade exactly and I done some
prior research when after getting off
that my sex drive was just gone
and so I realized at that point that
oftentimes the hormonal birth control
that many women on especially young
women like they we kind of do this this
pattern where when we're young we do
like the hormonal you know daily birth
control and then we kind of graduate
from that to some others maybe like
longer form birth control and then you
know maybe in our 30s or after we've had
a couple kids we start considering like
an IUD which is a more permanent less
fussy remedy but when I got off the
hormonal birth control
yeah I'd started doing some research and
apparently it really blunts your
testosterone production and that
afterwards it doesn't come back we see
women so we don't work with a lot of men
under 30 but we do work with some women
under 30 because birth control or even
having a kid can I mean well I can think
of a 23 year old girl is healthy fit I
had a baby and just jacked our hormones
up yeah alright and so what's cool thing
with women and younger women is
sometimes adding testosterone for a
short amount of time
can like restart the wheel and then they
renormalize because once you get the
testosterone up to where it should be
the body's like oh yeah we felt better
here that was great and then you can
pull it out and the body will continue
to do it to that almost to that extent
nice yeah that's pretty cool as we get
older though our body's not as resilient
and it doesn't want especially for guys
like you know you can have a guys you
can have an injury up riding your bike
and hit yourself injury a testicular
injury something like that and just that
you have low testosterone that actually
happened to me I'd look testosterone at
like 23 but I was fit I worked out like
a maniac so the doctors like what do you
really want this for but and so that was
something that it helped me become a
little bit more compassionate to people
who have these needs and there wasn't
really a solution out there for them to
get it done yeah I know with me any
doctor I went to with my testosterone
levels they always said it's it it was
normal right and but it didn't feel
normal like my libido wasn't
non-existent but it wasn't great and I
didn't I just didn't feel I didn't feel
consistent I didn't feel the energy and
so what we did after looking at my blood
work which we'll go over here in a bit
was determined like okay maybe we need
to add a little bit of testosterone and
to see if that if that changes the way
that that you feel and there are a few
other things we looked at as well DHEA
and and at first sleep etc and you know
I think we're at this phase where we're
still tweaking a little bit and figuring
out what works and and what won't work
and what what is the more permanent
solution but I can tell you and I thank
you personally but I might as well thank
you on the podcast here like we've made
some significant changes well made
significant tweaks that are like pivots
but if you make a 15-degree pivot in one
direction you end up in a completely
different destination a month later two
months later five months later and and
that's really what I'm learning here
it's not the the magic pill or bullet or
whatever or magic cream I guess in this
case and what it is is it is a way for
us to to enhance the already good habits
that that are that are there yeah
absolutely and I think that what's great
too is a couple
doing that journey together we see the
most success too because there are a
couple things sometimes we can be
resentful when one of yeah one of the
spouses is feeling great right and or
the other side of it is think of it
about two individuals in a place that
love each other they're attracted each
other
but like they just they're like I don't
even know why I don't want to like
pursue intimacy and put that playfulness
and that can be hormones right and then
it could lead to just a bunch of other
things but if their hormones are
optimized now they're a little bit more
like hey and you know and it's and then
you're playful in that it's good for the
relationship and like all that stuff
could come from just but you know having
better hormones yeah you know what I
mean it's important that was one thing
that stood out in the questions that got
asked there were a hundred and thirty
questions or something about hormones
hormones that solicited on her Instagram
yeah i solicited for questions for this
a minimal wellness by the way you want
to follow her yeah and um not a single
question I think they were all from
women to be fair but like still not a
single question about sex drive and that
just blew my mind
blew my mind well I think we're often in
public we're embarrassed to talk about
these things yeah and I think
something's wrong with us right now
that's not but it just can be a hormone
man yeah or you know what if something
is quote-unquote wrong it's okay to have
something wrong
especially for trying to pursue some
sort of solution toward improving it
right and with me and backs like we've
had a great sex life for the last five
years but I can tell you recently it's
been even better and so so like by
tweaking a few things now she has to
like hide in the bathroom and lock
herself in there I'm chasing her around
the house and stuff but I think it's
bonded yes it can it could potentially
save relationships it could save
marriages and and it can save the way
you look at yourself and all those
things and that's what really got me in
this base ten years ago because I saw
that outcome of it I was like whoa
that's powerful yes we got another
question you're old before you get that
hand out let me send you a couple
tickets to our tour stop we're going to
go on tour and a few months here and we
have a stop in San Diego we have
actually we're taking a podcast on the
road to a bunch of cities you
find the dates over at the minimalists
comm a slash tour we're gonna have a
guest in each city also a musical guest
we're gonna do a live version of the
podcast and some other special things as
well the minimalists column slash tour
to find a city near you if your city
isn't there you can just enter your
email address will notify you when we
were coming to the city closest to you
but Hanna will send you a couple tickets
to our San Diego event Diana from
Instagram has a question what's the link
between hormones and anxiety and
depression is it different for women
than it is for men
so Adam Beck's was talking about this
earlier like there was there was
something that was off this winter and
it can be seasonal it can be you know a
lack of vitamin D which is a hormone
right now now do you find that it's
different for men and women and and what
hormones contribute to this this anxiety
and depression yeah I think that you
know the number one thing we believe is
testosterone is a good foundational
hormone to address first why is it the
sort of why is it them the Silver Bullet
for so many people because it seems like
when you fix that other things fall in
line yeah it's because it's like a
dominant hormone right so you know when
you think of testosterone you don't
think of like we wimpy whiny little
right you think big strong tough and
that's really like what it can do in
your body so it can it can change just
how you respond to things how you react
things like that and so just from the
question about stress and anxiety like
some things may not bother you if your
testosterone optimized but if your
testosterones low it's just it's gonna
affect you more you're more likely to be
a bother by it in testosterone when
testosterone is in a place where it
should be for your body where your
body's happy with your testosterone
levels other areas regulate too whether
it's estrogen estradiol which are both
important for men and women DHEA levels
even thyroid issues you know we see
every time just about we see thyroid and
function improvement when testosterone
is optimal right so instead of loading
someone with thyroid and
didn't even check that you know like a
woman in particular didn't even check
their testosterone it's super low
potentially elevating their testosterone
to a better level for their lifestyle
could eliminate the need for any thyroid
intervention right so some of those
things were just never looked at make
sense with how many people are on
thyroid medications especially women
that seems like really prescribed yeah
hormone drug in the country without a
lot of people or through minimal
wellness minimal wellness calm by the
way and a lot of people just mention
thyroid like right away right it's like
a thing that comes up and I think often
it's it's a guess everybody I got a
thyroid issue sometimes we see their
blood work like no you don't you
actually don't you may have a discipline
issue with your nighttime eating or
something like or you're an extreme
person that like you know like I think I
wouldn't like the competitive Fitness
people a lot of times they're like you
know the extreme diets and so with that
you can check your thyroid up you know
all kinds of different things
stress and stuff like that so you can
check your thyroid all right well Diana
let me send you because one other thing
to think about with respect to
depression is your values and we have a
free values worksheet on our website the
minimalists comm /v you can download
that there's also an essay there called
how to understand your values and I
think quite often we experience anxiety
not specifically depression but anxiety
we experience quite a bit when our
actions don't align with our values well
if you don't know what your values are
it's pretty hard to align your daily
actions with your long-term values so I
want you get really clear on what your
values are Ryan and I believe there are
four different types of values and there
are specific examples there over the
minimalists comm /v you can check that
out alright it's time for our lightning
round
Adam backs this is where I answer
questions from our the text message
questions from our audience you can text
your questions and comments to nine
thirty seven two oh two four six five
four those texts literally go to Ryan's
and my phones we answer as many as we
can via text we also answer some here on
the podcast now Adam during the
lightning round this is where we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we call the minimal maxims
podcast Shawn puts them in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pit the answers on social media if
they'd like
all of our pithy answers are now in one
place as well minimal Maxim's calm
really we just ramble on a bit until we
get something that's that's we double or
not
Kimberly has a question for us Beck's
you want to read this question for us
yeah
so Kimberly asks what's the best way to
determine hormone levels blood work what
about the testing it was the stop
casting start test yeah okay yeah that's
so so I mean that is the thing you know
we often hear you can't manage what you
what you don't measure and that's really
the same thing I mean for me my pity
answer is actually in that same vein
it's hard to fix a problem without a
name yeah and so sometimes like this
this winter Beck's you were like
something feels off well feels off is
not a diagnosis really right hard to fix
a problem without a name can also lead
to depression too because just when you
reach that point of like I can't solve
this like I'm no longer qualified to
figure out what is going on with me and
I don't even know where else to begin
right that stuff that's gonna take you
to depression yeah right and so when you
can be a resource and you know things
like the blood work and say oh guess
what you're just awesome Israel oh
that's why you're like oh right the
answer is there and how we feel better
we feel confident because there's a
there's potentially a path of what we
can go into and it's game-changing and
if people want to do a test they can
just go to renew life rx comm you yeah
just about information one of our team
one of our wellness coordinators will
call them and like roll them right
through the process and by the way I
don't get anything for telling you to go
there I want to be clear you know we
don't do any advertisements or anything
like that it's just Adams help both of
us and I thought this would be really
compelling for our audience both men and
women because a lot of people are
starting to ask that question is they
feel like backs where like I feel like
I'm doing things right but something is
off I felt the same way and and
something was off and and getting the
tests made a lot of sense also we got Co
vid test three that's how Bex and I
found out we definitively we thought we
had Co vid but like we knew definitively
after doing the antibodies test which
are on your website as well yeah we can
sometimes just we just add that to the
panel if people want to get that done
and so like just a hormone panel is you
know it's usually unless we do something
special it's around three hundred
dollars which is the testing the
overview and all that stuff which is
pretty
portable to potentially solve a major
question go round in your life right now
good yes indeed good to hear back to
your self-pity for us yes I said data is
good but it's useless without corrective
and supporting lifestyles that's the
other thing too B's you can get this
test and look at it and frame it and
look at it every day but if it if it
doesn't mean you make some sort of
corrections in your own life and your
own habits or in in supplementation if
necessary then it's just data right and
there's some times where we there
doesn't everybody we see we doesn't mean
we help like if we can't help you
we're not gonna help you eat from that
same point but we definitely are gonna
at least try to direct you in a place to
where you know we just look at some
other things and figure out we had a guy
recently just Ostrow knows like through
the roof hi I mean it's sex
hormone-binding globulin it was to do
the roof high the highest I've ever seen
i pricing ten thousand people's blood
work yeah I mean the highest I've ever
seen that so I says listen I want you
understand it's not like oh yeah you're
kind of high the highest I've ever seen
and so we just advised him went
somewhere potentially local to pursue
like just to see what's going on and and
you know because it's very unique and
different a little bit out of our
wheelhouse potentially all right well
before we get into our added value
segment today looks like we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week here
are a few of them I'm dead set against
hormone replacement therapy do I need
more education we'll talk about that
also we're gonna talk more about how
diet sleep sunlight and exercise affect
our hormones we'll talk more about sex
drive we're gonna talk about skin and
hair health and how that's tied to
hormones for sure we're gonna talk about
acne problems pregnancy birth control
hypothyroidism and mental health and
we're also going to review Becca's and
my before and after hormone test results
and we're talking about how we made some
subtle improvements actually made some
subtle changes that made big
improvements in our life also got a
million more questions for Adam Lam if
you wanna hear all that check out our
maximal episodes on the minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate podcast and it's just a couple
bucks and it's the most honest way for
the minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisement so we
make money only if you find value in and
support what we create head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support too
grab and get your personal link so that
our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app and here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners this week Fillie from the UK
here i've been catching up on your
podcasts and occasionally hear people
who want to give up convenient shopping
such as Amazon to help them avoid
mindless consumption this won't work for
everyone but I have found that I can
often completely switch off the desire
for a brand if I look into their
production in more detail this could be
the way they treat people the planet
animals how they deal with toxic waste
what they invest in and so on in the UK
this information is easily found with
the magazine ethical consumer but I do
pay to subscribe to them some of their
research is free I don't know if there
is a u.s. equivalent but they do cover
many global brands I find this helps me
create a barrier to easy consumption and
it has helped me avoid acquiring
countless items over the past few years
and also ensures I am very intentional
about what I do buy hopefully this could
help others too my name is Betty I'm
from upstate New York I have a message
for Jane the woman on your podcast about
building a tiny house and she was
looking for ways to minimize her kitchen
I recommend looking into an instant pot
it's all-in-one pressure cooker slow
cooker rice cooker yogurt maker I it's
best if you youtube or google it rather
than listen to me rave about it but it
sure saves a lot of space and it saves
on extra appliances alright y'all for
this minimal episode that's it for now I
want to thank you Adam lamb for joining
us today
courage folks to go to renew life rx
comm also we didn't get a chance to talk
about this but maybe we'll get to it on
the maximal episode you wrote a book
called better than the binge overcoming
the social obligation of alcohol so
we'll put a link to this book in there
as well because I mean there are a lot
of people who struggle with alcohol or
maybe don't even realize that they
struggle with alcohol and become
dependent on it without realizing
they're dependent and the thing I often
hear is well I'm not an alcoholic I just
drink four or five hours over some
right yeah that's a calmness Pez Jim so
right right and so so you talk about
your own journey of letting that go for
90 days and what that did for your life
and and then how you move forward from
there I will put a link to that book in
the show notes as well but renew life rx
comm will be in the show notes for folks
to check out as well if you're
interested in testing or if you have any
questions for Adam as well for added
value this week I was gonna recommend
Lionel Shrivers new book but Bexon Isis
Beck's is here we've been reading a book
at night by James Frey called Katerina
so back sighs we read together every
night and like right before bed yes but
it's funny because we're talk about
testosterone hormones also stuff and
it's a very sort of sex riddled book I'm
going to caveat it yeah it's funny
because reading it out loud often leads
to sex immediately after so it's it was
that way when we started the book it's
beautifully written as well and it works
very well auditorally so a great book
James Frey Katarina we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well that's
our added value this week and real quick
four right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalist we have a side project called
minimalism life it's sort of the best of
minimalist well-being
that's the minimalist and then also
minimalist design that's our friends
over a minimally Simo Carl in particular
and then minimalist travel our friends
at five style we came together and we
started the side project called
minimalism life and it's the best of
minimalism for all from all walks of
life and the website for that is
minimalism dot life if you want to
follow beautiful photos of minimalism
life you can do that on Instagram as
well it's just at minimalism life on
Instagram or at minimalism on Twitter
it's a great side project it's really
beautiful
we have three writers over there who
also write about minimalism you can find
all kinds of architecture and design
free wallpapers minimalist wallpapers
for your smartphone or desktop as well
minimalism dot life is the website you
can
follow the minimalists on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
just visit the minimalists comm slash
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalistic if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
e-mail list over the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails whenever we send those and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope what's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus